[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
voici les titres de ce mercredi 27 mai
cela fait partie de la stratégie de
déconfinement augmenter considérablement
le nombre de tests à lakovic 19
reportage au laboratoire de montigny le
bretonneux qui après 16 heures accueil
des personnes présentant des symptômes
du virus pour des dépistages cette
semaine pour améliorer le secteur le
gouvernement a donné lundi le coup
d'envoi du ségur de la santé en pleine
crise sanitaire
quant à temps le monde médical éléments
de réponse avec le professeur philippe
rousselot et chef de service à l'hôpital
mignot du chesnay rocancourt et c'est
sans doute l'effet direct de deux mois
de confinement les demandes de maisons
avec jardins ont explosé ces dernières
semaines la tendance s'observe également
dans les yvelines par les professionnels
de l'immobilier
avant de développer ses titres les
annonces du ministre de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui concernant le deuxième tour
des élections municipales christophe
castaner à préciser certaines modalités
du scrutin prévu le 28 juin prochain
le dépôt des listes des candidats devra
s'effectuer du vendredi 29 mai au mardi
2 juin elle la campagne officielle
elle s'ouvrira le lundi 15 juin soit
deux semaines avant le passage aux urnes
dans les yvelines les électeurs d'une
quarantaine de communes sont convoqués
pour choisir leurs maires et leurs
conseillers municipaux et depuis le
début du déconfinement la demande de
dépistage du coronavirus a largement
augmenté dans le même temps le nombre de
personnes positif détecté semble
diminuer c'est ce qu'observe en tout cas
le laboratoire de montigny le bretonneux
ou des tests sont effectués chaque jour
le reportage de manon varaldo et
d'aurélie ronces à 16h le laboratoire
ferme ses portes pour accueillir les
personnes présentant des symptômes
évocateurs du coc vide 19 et ainsi
éviter le contact avec la patiente est
l'habituel ces personnes peuvent
bénéficier d'un dépistage par test pcr
par voie nasale
le test est assez rapide en soi puisque
c'est un prélèvement dans les deux
narines on a introduit un écouvillon à
ses fins jusqu'au nasopharynx donc ça va
assez loin
et voilà donc le test dure quelques
minutes un chaque jour une vingtaine de
personnes est testé dans ce laboratoire
de retour d'un séjour à l'étranger cette
patiente souffre d'une dégradation de
son état respiratoire
j'ai fait un voyage en république
dominicaine au mois de mars et les
premiers signes de va dire de tout son
arrivée à mon retour pour effectuer le
dépistage du coronavirus il ne faut en
aucun cas se rendre directement dans le
laboratoire de biologie
le rendez vous se prend au préalable par
email afin d'éviter et tous documents
susceptibles d'être contaminés le virus
peut donner une palette de symptômes
très variés les enveloppes sont pas
vraiment reconnue comme un symptôme
courant mais c'est les personnes jeunes
c'était pas mal observé par les dermatos
même si ce n'est pas garanti à côté de
ça j'avais un peu de mal de tête en fait
température les personnes identifiées
comme cas contacts peuvent également se
faire dépister c'est le cas de cette
mère de famille mais ça bouge thiebe
vomissements courbatures gfr un
supplément de rendement
tareen le test est facile à effectuer
non invasif mais désagréable pour le
patient car un peu douloureux
les résultats sont communiqués dans les
24 heures en attendant le médecin
préconise de rester à son domicile
tendance donc à la baisse observée dans
ce laboratoire même si dans les yvelines
les derniers chiffres sont plutôt à la
hausse si l'on regarde les données de
santé publique france 487 personnes sont
décédées du coronavirus dans le
département soit huit victimes
supplémentaires en 24 heures
le nombre d'hospitalisations est
également légère augmentation 595
patients étaient hospitalisés sur le
territoire ce mardi lé réanimation elle
baisse et s'établissent désormais à 38
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
mille huit cent soixante et une
personnes ont été guéries après un
passage à l'hôpital dans les yvelines
quelle est la situation si l'on place
maintenant le curseur plus
spécifiquement à l'hôpital andré mignot
du chesnay rocancourt l'occasion aussi
de voir quelles sont les attentes du
monde médical sur place concernant le
ségur de la santé je vous le disais dans
les titres il a été lancé lundi par le
gouvernement
l'entretien est menée par marylène yapi
chinois le 25 mai dernier le président
de la république promettait un plan
massif d'investissements et de
revalorisation à l'issue de la crise
sanitaire
ce lundi 25 mai deux mois pile après
cette annonce le premier ministre et son
ministre de l'intérieur lancé ce qu'ils
appellent le ségur de la santé avec 300
acteurs du monde de la santé
nous sommes en communication avec
philippe rousselot chef de service à
l'hôpital mignot au chesnay rocancourt
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
tout d'abord comment allez vous et
comment avez vous vécu cette crise à
l'hôpital mignon bah je vous remercie
forte heureusement nous allons tous bien
comme vous le savez le plat de mignot
était un hôpital de référence pour le
coc vide dans les yvelines qui a été un
département particulièrement touché et
on a vécu comme dans beaucoup d'autres
endroits en région parisienne dans le
grand est
la saturation du système de santé mais
l'hôpital a tenu bon et je crois que ça
s'est vraiment à mettre au crédit de
l'ensemble des équipes et l'ensemble des
acteurs qui ont travaillé dans l'hôpital
avec effectivement un pic au moment le
plus fort de l'épidémie de pratiquement
150 patients hospitalisés pour maladie
qu l'idée est de pratiquement 50
patients en réanimation
hélas le rectum en a vécu la décrue
comme partout ailleurs et il ya
quasiment pratiquement plus patients
dialysés pour maladie colline en
médecine un dizaine tout au plus et de
la même façon le nom de la soirée le
match on a beaucoup diminué moins de 10
actuellement et sur ces dernières
semaines on a eu deux nouveaux patients
admis donc il reste encore un fonds
d'infection virale avec quelques formes
graves mais qui est sans commune mesure
avec ce qu'on a connu il ya encore
quatre semaines
or justement durant le confinement la
population française s'est montrée
plutôt solidaires il se souvient les
applaudissements et les soirs à 20h
mais l'hiver donc de blues masques et
même des repas est ce que vous vous
sentez soutenu alors on s'est beaucoup
sorti soutenu par la population c'est
vrai que l'ensemble des soignants que ce
soit les gens directement impliqués dans
la prise en charge des patients atteints
de coded comme mes collègues
réanimateurs mes collègues médecins
infectiologues ou que moi qui suit y est
tous en deuxième ligne qui m'occupais de
passion justement qu'il fallait protéger
du coc vide on s'est tous sentis très
soutenu par ses applaudissements
de même que les personnels soignants
médico-technique quoique on a pu vivre
une grande unité du monde hospitalier à
l'issue de temps pendant cette crise
noire avant cette crise vous étiez déjà
mobilisés à plusieurs reprises pour
alerter sur la dégradation de l'hôpital
vous avez même menacé de démissionner de
vos fonctions administratives quelle
était la situation
la situation était celle d'un constat
est en fait un constat hérité de
plusieurs années presque une dizaine
d'années et qui était un constat
essentiellement
de manque budgétaire et de moyens
c'était le premier constat est le
deuxième compte a été un constat de
manque d'attractivité
donc ces deux constats pour nous donc
les les soignants qui font partie du
collectif inter hôpitaux le cih pour
nous faisait peser une menace sur le
futur de l'hôpital public donc c'était
vraiment s'inquiéter
la motivation pour alerter les pouvoirs
publics et ça passait par des
revendications très simple qui était de
revaloriser les salaires les plus bas de
la fonction publique hospitalière
ça passait par la décision au niveau de
la nation que d'euros budgétés
correctement les hôpitaux
ça passait par également une réflexion
sur le nombre de livres les hôpitaux qui
était nécessaire pour assumer certaines
missions et je pense que cette ses
revendications restent d'actualité et
elles ont été quelque part mis en
exergue par l'épidémie a kobe de 19
mais finalement les le constat était
déjà là justement j'en arrive à
aujourd'hui cette semaine le
gouvernement a lancé en ses murs de la
santé un mois de concertation avec pour
objectif d'améliorer les conditions de
travail et les rémunérations du secteur
qu'est ce que vous en attendez alors là
on attend beaucoup et on espère que ça
soit à hauteur de nos attentes
je crois qu'on a tous été très
positivement
on n'a toujours reçu très positivement
l'annoncé d'une revalorisation des
salaires parce que c'était quand même le
point de départ de retrouver une
certaine attractivité à l'hôpital et
puis peut-être qu'on est un petit peu
déçu de ce qui est en train de se jouer
sur la gouvernance on aimerait bien que
le sujet de la gouvernance soit un petit
peu plus à l'ordre du jour parce que
derrière les révélations salariale
derrière le budget hospitalier
il ya les modes de fonctionnement qui
sont et qui ont été mis en question ce
qu'on a vécu moment de la crise du coc
vide c'est une grande unité de l'hôpital
mais pas que l'hôpital de l'hôpital dans
son territoire d ensemble des acteurs de
santé que ce soit les cliniques qui ont
pris des patients les hôpitaux qui ont
pris en charge les urgences les médecins
généralistes qui se sont occupés de la
prise en charge des patients à leur
domicile et c'est donc on a vu que le
système santé était capable de s'unifier
pour une mission commune qui était
apporté une réponse à un besoin de santé
alors c'est sûr que ça s'est fait au
détriment de toutes les autres pris en
charge donc c'est qu'un parti
officiel cette unité mais elle a quand
même eu lieu est ce qu'on souhaite c'est
qu'on reste dans cette dynamique
unitaire au sein de l'hôpital et des
acteurs de santé tels que on retrouve
les complémentarités et en sortent de
cette politique de cloisonnement qui a
été favorisée par trop d'instance des
structures sur d'autres structures etc
parlez trop grande différenciation entre
des métiers qui travaillent en silo et
par également un mode de tarification
qui fait qu' on s'est retrouvés tous en
concurrence les uns avec les autres
l'hôpital public avec les autres acteurs
de soins mais également au sein de
peut-être public ses services entre eux
et tout ça ça a nui à une synergie qu'on
a dû tellement efficaces et adaptées
face à une situation de crise
retrouver cette énergie ont aussi parlé
des rémunérations sont les priorités
peut-être qu'ils devraient ressortir de
ce seigneur la rémunération c'était la
conversation numéro un du collectif
inter hôpitaux etc ce qui de notre point
de vue est la base d'une refondation de
l'attractivité de l'hôpital mais à côté
de ça même si les gens sont mieux payés
si leurs possibilités de faire carrière
à l'hôpital l'évolution de leur métier
qu'ils soient soignants paramédical
techniciens médicaux techniques
administratifs n'est pas également pris
en compte
je pense que le salaire ne fait pas tout
donc le salaire c'est vraiment l'élément
lapierre de balles sur lequel on doit
bâtir le futur mais mais derrière il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire sur la
dynamique d'attractivité l'évolution des
métiers et également faire en sorte que
les cloisonnements qui sont très
importants dans les différents métiers
soit un petit peu moins forts et
permettent de meilleure collaboration de
meilleures synergies et tout le monde
s'y retrouvera et tout ça c'est
l'objectif d'être au service des
patients et de répondre à leurs besoins
de santé plutôt que de répondre à des
impératifs budgétaires et économiques
vraiment on voulait vraiment se
recentrer sur les besoins de santé de la
population dont on a la charge
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
merci philippe rousseau d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
merci à vous je rappelle vous êtes chef
de service à l'hôpital andré mignot au
finir au concours merci maître dans
l'actualité économique
renault va miser sur son alliance avec
nissan et mitsubishi pour réduire les
coûts
annonce ce matin du président de la
marque au losange jean dominique senard
d'après nos confrères du figaro les
conséquences de ce plan pourrait se
traduire par la suppression de 5000
postes en france soit 10% des effectifs
du groupe
deux sites seraient menacés l' usine de
flins sur seine qui emploie 2600
personnes ne serait pas concernée mais
son activité pourrait évoluer le
gouvernement qui pourrait débloquer un
plan de soutien de 5 milliards d'euros
attend désormais des garanties de
maintien d'emplois par renault et les
annonces du groupe sont attendus ce
vendredi
c'est officiel depuis lundi skywest a
été racheté par la société des grands
magasins le centre commercial de 30
mille mètres carrés où l'on retrouve
plusieurs enseignes de loisirs et de
divertissement est implantée à montigny
le bretonneux un site vendus par la
société hammerson qui reste tout de même
propriétaire de l'espace saint quentin
centre commercial attenant
on écoute le directeur des opérations de
la société des grands magasins
interrogés par nicolas landry est ouest
la plupart un emplacement on est dans
une zone résidentielle une zone riche en
activités en bureau en entreprise donc
on a identifié un vrai potentiel et qui
aujourd'hui ne semble sous-exploité
parce que le centile est remplie hier un
peu plus de la moitié des rentrées aux
deux tiers et on sait qu'il ya encore un
travail à mener sur ce centre pour
exploiter tout son potentiel et qu'on va
réellement continuer cette stratégie en
s'axant sur le divertissement sur le
loisir et puis renforcé un petit pot si
leur prestation qui accompagnera est la
configuration se prête parfaitement aux
loisirs avec des grandes cellules
disponibles sur les deux premiers
niveaux et pour accélérer le
remplacement du centre est espéré à
horizon 12 à 18 mois
le remplir à 100% on a identifié
quelques acteurs et avec trois ou quatre
acteurs qui prendrait des très grosses
cellules on arrivera à remplir
l'ensemble chante elle est désormais
active la préfecture des yvelines a
lancé une cellule des soutiens aux
entreprises l'objectif accompagner les
structures en difficulté et veiller à la
mobilisation des mesures
gouvernementales liées à la crise
sanitaire activité partielle remises
d'impôts ou encore prêts garantis par
l'état la cellule peut être saisi sur
simple demande du responsable de la
société ou sur recommandation
c'est en effet peut-être inattendue de
mois de confinement les français
recherchent aujourd'hui de l'espace ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux à vouloir
une maison avec jardin les
professionnels de l'immobilier observe
en effet un boom des demandes depuis
quelques semaines et les yvelines sont
aussi concernés par cet intérêt regardez
ce sujet de mélanie poker voilà un bien
qui pourrait devenir encore plus rare
une maison avec jardin
après deux mois de confinement les
envies immobilières ont quelque peu
changé ses agents spécialisés dans les
maisons de familles ont reçu des
demandes et la troisième semaine de
confinement sur le deuxième mois de
confinement
ça a vraiment été beaucoup plus
intensifs pour vous donner des chiffres
concrets sur la même et même période
l'an dernier
donc le mois de mars et mois d'avril on
a connu une augmentation de + 110 % de
la demande sur des maisons avec jardin
dans l'ouest parisien
le plus important pour les sites à danse
avec d'avoir un espace extérieur quels
qu'ils soient un petit peu de verdure
même une terrasse plus que le
confinement l'évolution des modes de
travail pourrait renforcer cette
recherche dans les yvelines après le 11
mai moins de 10% des salariés ont
réintégré leur entreprise
ça c'est une tendance assez générale à
avoir une pièce de plus pour les gens
qui peuvent se mettre en télétravail
évidemment il faut que l'activité qui
est la leur
leur permettent de le faire mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de bureau
et qui souhaiteraient avoir un bureau
dédié pouvoir travailler de manière
efficace à distance un boom qui ne
pourrait être qu'un effet de mode pour
la fédération nationale de l'immobilier
entre 67 et 83% des personnes ne
changerait pas leur envie je vois mal
quelqu'un qui assemble du roi la défense
un appartement à neuilly sur seine pour
que c'est juste à côté peut y aller à
pied ou alors à une station de métro à
les acheter une maison à versailles ou
un peu plus loin avant jardin parce que
le gars comme à y revenir
et cette envie de jardin pourrait se
voir arrêter par un obstacle le budget
certains professionnels redoutent que
les banques réduisent les prêts aux
particuliers
ce nouvel incendie qui a touché
l'entreprise gde implantée dans la zone
portuaire de limay la nuit dernière un
feu a été signalé à 23h15 et a nécessité
l'intervention de près de cinq ans
sapeurs pompiers des yvelines 50 tonnes
de ferraille ont été détruites par les
flammes le sinistre aurait été causé par
une ou plusieurs batteries au lithium
deuxième incendie en deux mois pour
l'entreprise le 15 avril dernier un
incendie sur place avaient déjà détruit
et 1500 tonnes de matériaux l'entreprise
gde n'est pas un site classé seveso
alors que la réouverture des cinémas est
espérée début juillet votre rubrique
dans les salles est devenu dans vos
canapés des cinéastes et exploitant des
yvelines vous donnent leur sélection de
films à voir et directement depuis chez
vous comme il ya deux semaines c'est jen
assure réalisatrice de chevreuse qui se
prête à l'exercice regarder alors un
autre film aussi que j'adore un autre
style c'est un film américain c'est même
d'ailleurs il ya eu une trilogie c'est
la trilogie des before sunrise et before
sunrise parle d'un américain à un jeune
américain qui rencontre une française à
vienne est ce que j'aime beaucoup avec
ce film aussi c'est que c'est vraiment
une comme un rite de passage et une
rencontre au voyage
c'est à dire ces deux personnes qui sont
tellement différentes l'une de l'autre
se retrouve dans un train et décide de
passer la journée ensemble
et puis de cela arrive une très grande
histoire d'amour une telle rencontre une
belle réflexion aussi sur ce qu'est
l'amour la vie en général on va vous
posiez des généraux
les cheveux gras c'est dans sa
[Musique]
et tout ça à travers cette espèce de
parcours initiatique temps viennent des
deux personnages principaux qui sont
interprétés par julie des qui est fan
dok exact est vraiment exceptionnel et
donc j'ai choisi before sunrise parce
que c'est le premier mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup les deux suivants puisque a eu
toute une trilogie before succèdent qui
se passe à paris et before midnight se
passe en grèce et des films que vous
pouvez louer ou acheter sur des sites
internet du centre national du cinéma ou
de la cinéthèque voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]